thanks for joining us and you got the
lemon tree in the back we're right on
brand with the squeeze let's make the
lemonade right yeah
oh here's the discussion now because we
were just like well what color is this
jacket now it's like pink and everyone's
everyone's got a name everyone's got
different names for the colors so we
don't even need to go there that's
here's here's where we're at
what would that be oh see that's what's
happening now now the whole interview is
I'm gonna be like I'm asking a question
of like no I think it's magenta like
that's what's gonna happen
like a
why did this come to my head like a
Dusty Rose like a like a Dusty Rose like
pink color yeah I mean that might just
be the flowers he has in the corner yes
I could do that too but see this is this
is why the podcast Works Taylor you're
like okay I'm think of something and
then tagos here's the here's like the
artistic interpretation because it's a
real deal about what we're going to talk
about right now Dusty Rose
um I I I'm a huge fan of what you guys
are doing with this because I love the
idea of you two you're a couple and
really just diving into conversations
about
um
the world around you but through your
own experiences and through your
experiences with each other you know I
want to know the origin story of this
because so many people will say ah we
get along so well we should start a
podcast but y'all just went ahead and
were like let's do this podcast what's
where did this come from
it's it started with Tay I mean
when was it she she started a Blog
called lemons by Tay about a year ago
and then a non-profit called the lemons
foundation and then one morning she woke
up and she told me hey I think uh I'm
gonna do a podcast and I was like okay
have fun with that and she was like no
you're gonna be a part of it too and I
was like excuse me
um and she's she's smart though she was
like you can just be my part-time
co-host whenever you want to join but
she knew I would get the bug and I knew
once we filmed one episode he was gonna
be like oh I actually want to do this
and that's exactly what happened so I
just let him come to the decision on his
own yeah I just needed to do it myself I
knew he was going to be so good at I
mean he's so good at talking and
relating to people so I knew he was yeah
hey it seems like you've got his number
already like you already know this guy
you know but here's the thing you guys
are having these conversations how much
more are you learning about each other
as you're doing this uh podcast
yeah that's the cool thing is I mean we
definitely I mean we've been together
for five years now but and so we know
each other's deepest darkest Secrets but
it is pretty cool to see how much more
you can learn even when you thought you
knew everything about somebody through
these intentional conversations and then
having our guests on each week you know
that brings up a topic that you're like
whoa I never even thought of that yeah
it gives Like A New Perspective or like
a
something that we've never thought
thought of and we're like oh wait that's
a great idea or maybe that's why this
happened so it's it's been really cool
each time we're like whoa
how often even or you know as early as
you are in this podcast that you guys
are doing do you come away from having
those conversations with guests and then
the conversations between two of you
continue on and on and you keep you know
discussing or dissecting what you guys
learned or what you thought you knew
even after you guys have stopped
recording oh yeah every yeah every time
every week literally
finish recording and the person will
leave we we filmed the podcast in our
house we really wanted to like invite
people into our home and make it feel
like a safe place for everyone
um so when they leave our home uh or if
it's virtually we're just like oh my
gosh like their stories are all
incredible they have something that we
can relate to and they've we've had
several guests so far that have helped
me like realize things about myself like
I I openly talk about on the podcast all
the time that I'm still I am no expert
by any means like I'm in the middle of
this journey and I'm trying to figure
out you know I'm trying to put my finger
on why I do certain things
um why I react certain ways I don't know
uh and sometimes that's frustrating but
it's been really cool because some of
our guests have actually kind of had
that answer for me and I'm like wow I
feel like I yeah I feel like I owe you
some money for this therapy I know it's
like therapy every time and the best way
we come out of it we're like oh wow that
was learn something new the real focus
on mental health and like you know I was
I was literally just listening to Taylor
you talking about your own mental health
with regards to like your body image
because of you know uh Twilight and
everything that you were doing there and
what what you feel like the world
expected of you and what you expected of
yourself
um when you have when you're thinking
about people listening is part of the
idea of telling these stories to really
help them perhaps get through something
that they're getting through who because
they might not have someone like a Tay
or a tailor to talk to
yeah for sure for sure because I I don't
think I even admitted it to myself until
somewhat recently
um it was actually
a very good friend of mine who kind of
deals with a similar thing
um that sort of helped me come to the
conclusion that hey this is something
that I deal with and I'm not the only
person so
um yeah I definitely
want I've never really talked about that
and I made the decision that I want to
because I can only imagine the amount of
people that deal with that same thing
and it's um it's not a fun thing to live
in but
um I've learned that you can overcome it
and
um there's a lot more important things
in life than what your brain thinks you
look like in a mere naked it
um
so yeah it definitely was important for
me to just be honest about that and uh
just share my story if that can help
anybody in any way you know we already
thought your podcast kind of like blow
up the internet a little bit with you
know Taylor you talking about your story
about Kanye at the VMAs a while back
tape for you what was it like listening
to I mean I'm sure you've heard the
story before and you were telling us for
the podcast but what was it like for you
hearing his perspective on that whole
event
yeah I mean I definitely heard the story
before but I had no idea he was gonna
say that as the answer to the question
and so when we were filming the podcast
I was like oh my gosh this is the most
amazing thing he could have ever said
because I just wasn't expecting it at
all I was expecting like I don't know I
don't even know what it sounds like
super serious serious steep answer but
no it I mean it's so true and I'm so
happy that he like gets to share like
that side of it because when you're up
there and you're presenting and you're
on stage you can't hear anything you
know so I I totally make sense of uh it
was just
it was fun to hear him tell the story
she's also she's also a big Swifty so I
am a Swifty hey yeah I knew she would
like that one
and when it comes to upcoming guests is
there any chance that you know we'll see
anyone from the Twilight movies as a
guest on your podcast because it would
be interesting to share you know in in
the spirit of openness that you guys
have in this podcast
your experiences and the story is that
you might share or might not even know
about each other's experiences yeah yeah
uh there definitely is a chance of that
and I I can tease that we already have a
co-star of mine in the can that will be
releasing within the next few weeks but
yeah we'll um you'll have to wait and
see
that's awesome well congratulations you
two uh on the podcast it's been a great
pleasure listening to it thank you so
much for taking the time thank you